[Musique]
été 1971 en californie
neuf jeunes hommes sont arrêtés fichier
est enfermé au sous-sol de l'université
stanford
transformé pour l'occasion en prison
c'est le début d'une des plus célèbres
expérience en psychologie
elle devait durer deux semaines
[Musique]
l'objectif du professeur philip zimbardo
et d'étudier les comportements en milieu
carcéral
les gardiens doivent montrer qui est le
patron devait faire preuve d'autorité
envers les prisonniers il recrute des
étudiants ont leur franc 15 dollars par
jour et les sépare en deux groupes
et prisonniers sont dépouillés de tous
leurs droits ils deviennent de simples
numéros
[Applaudissements]
mais garde le préservent leur anonymat
grâce aux costumes et aux lunettes
tous les participants sur libre d'agir
comme ils le veulent
rapidement l'expérience dérape et
prisonnier insultes des gardes qui
répliquent par des châtiments
[Musique]
la cruauté s'intensifie et devient hors
de contrôle
le cauchemar ne durera finalement que
six jours
nous avons dû arrêter l'expérience car
ce n'était plus une expérience nous
avions créé une prison et des gens
souffrir
pour philip zimbardo si la preuve que
n'importe qui peut devenir un monstre
que s'il contact l'environnement qui
pousse l'individu aux comportements les
plus barbares
l'étude passe à l'histoire elle sera
racontée au grand écran trois fois
plutôt qu'une
mais aujourd'hui ces conclusions sont
remises en question
notamment parce que certains
participants disent avoir joué la
comédie en simulant une crise de nerfs
ou en forçant la note sur la cruauté
pire encore les chercheurs sont
intervenus dans l'étude en demandant aux
gardes d'être plus dur envers les
prisonniers ce qui a pu influencer des
événements
et d'autres phénomènes peuvent expliquer
les résultats comme notre attirance face
à la tyrannie ou notre besoin de se
conformer coûte que coûte aux règles
d'un groupe
chose certaine en voulant explorer un
des recoins les plus sombres de l'esprit
mme l'expérience de standford a surtout
montré que tout n'est pas aussi noir et
blanc qu'on aimerait croire
[Musique]